okay thank you very much and uh
yeah let me thank the organizers for
giving me the opportunity to speak at
this really
interesting conference which has had
many great talks already so the bar has
been set very high so i hope i can live
up to that expectation also giving a
flagpole talk which i don't do that all
that often because usually i end up
showing a lot of numerical data
um but
showing data is apparently not allowed
here so i'm not going to do that and i'm
going to try to introduce the concepts
of many body localizations so the idea
of my talk is to explain what
many body localization means
and so uh
i i you know the goal is that everybody
understands it at the end so if
something is unclear please do ask me
and
i'm going to present the perspective on
many bitter localization that i
developed together with chetan nayak
and if you want to know any details or
look at the actual numerical results
i would point you to this
um paper now manually localization is a
very active field of research right now
so a lot of people are working on it
many of whom are in the audience and if
we already listed the people in the
audience who are working on this i'm not
going to repeat that and i'm just going
to
not
mention any references basically
throughout the talk
but i can give you the references if
you're interested or you can look them
up
in our paper
and i want to start out by giving a bit
of a motivation for why we would want to
study uh many body localization there
are two kind of
uh complementary perspectives on why
this is an interesting problem and then
at the very end of the talk i'm going to
be more specific and explain why we at
station q are interested in studying
many body localization which may not
seem very obvious from the beginning of
the talk
so one perspective is that of quantum
statistical mechanics
so in particular the question of how
thermodynamics or statistical mechanics
can arise in the close quantum system
which is of course a very old question
and uh many body localization is is kind
of another angle to look at this and in
particular answer the question
give some answer to the question for
what where in which systems
thermodynamics can emerge into close
quantum systems and in which systems it
actually fails and many body
localization will
provide maybe one of the few examples of
an interacting system where this
emergence of statistical mechanics
completely fails but let me first
discuss a little bit of what we would
expect in a kind of a generic clean
interacting quantum many-body system
this often goes by the name of eth
eigenstate thermalization hypothesis
which was put forward by deutsche
answered nikki in the early 90s
and i'm going to give a very
very weak definition of eigenstate
thermalization
so we consider some
large quantum system
and this is a closed quantum system so
this is somehow perfectly isolated from
the environment
i'm going to put this in a pure state
and this is going to be some eigenstate
to some hamiltonian
and i want this eigenstate to be really
highly excited so i want this to have a
finite energy density above the ground
state so if i take
the energy density above the ground
state per volume of this system
should be larger than zero so don't
imagine you know putting a few local
excitations in there but imagine putting
an extensive number of local excitations
into the system this is really a key
point
now
globally the system is in the pure state
doesn't have any entropy so you know
there's no notion of thermodynamics or
statistical mechanics there but we can
now cut out some region of this system
let's call this region a and this region
b
and the claim is
that
if you look at
quantities local in region a
those look thermal so if you look at the
reduced density matrix for a
so it trace out everything in b
and this is close to
some gibbs ensemble
and so this hamiltonian genetically will
be
this hamiltonian restricted to region a
and this inverse temperature beta here
will def depend in some way on the
energy density above the ground state
that are kind of globally put into the
system
um
and so the expectation is that this is
actually very generic behavior
so
how could how could i check this well
one thing you could do is you could
calculate local observables and compare
local observables against the uh
just the the gibbs ensemble and you
would see that um
tackling the local observable in an
eigen state well to some accuracy that
depends on the size of the system
um
match
expectation values either drawn from the
micro canonical ensemble or a canonical
ensemble for some inverse temperature
maybe in this uh audience the more
intuitive way to look at this is to
calculate the entanglement entropy of
this
radius density matrix
and then observe that this volume
follows the volume law so the
entanglement entropy here is
proportional to the volume of this
region a
this is not what we're used to thinking
about in tensor networks so we're
usually dealing with ground states of
local haemotomies which have an area
along but the important thing to
emphasize maybe at this point this may
be preaching to the choir but it's
really important to keep in mind that
this area is something that's extremely
specific to ground states of local
hamiltonians if you just take a random
quantum state it'll have a volume law if
you take a generic quantum system
and take a highly excited eyeing state
it'll have a volume law you can maybe
think of systems that are completely
diagonal in the product basis that will
not have this but then you can add a
small perturbation and you immediately
get a volume law so this volume law is
really an extremely generic property if
you're away from the ground state
and having this violated would be a very
strong indication of having quantum
statistical mechanics break down and
indeed we're going to see that many body
localization is an example of that
do you just mean um distribution yeah
that's what you have in mind yeah so we
don't have thermodynamics
by we have thermodynamics i mean
basically that something like this holds
and then local expectation values local
and a will match some gibbs
it gives distribution
um
okay now there's a
second and maybe historically
more you know the perspective that would
first come to mind when you think about
localization is that of transport
um
you know the first thing that comes to
mind when you think about what should a
localized system be it should be a
system that does not transport charge it
does not transport energy
um
so
how is this connected
um
and you can actually connect these at
least on a hand waving level uh but in a
very intuitive way so imagine some
disordered system so let's just take 1d
electrons
let's put them in a strong disorder
potential
so that
if there they're non-interacting all
like states are localized just to run
the anderson insulator
and now let's just for the sake of
argument add weak interactions
okay so some disorder potential
and now imagine you have an electron
sitting here
that is trying to make a hop over to
this side
if this picture of having
um kind of thermodynamics emerge locally
in your system is accurate what that
means is that the electrons in region b
can serve as the heat path for the
electrons in region a
so if you apply that notion over here
this electron could now in a sense
borrow some energy from that large heat
buff that it's surrounded by and both
that energy make the hop over this
barrier
and end up over here
is this the potential inside region a
that you drew schematically yeah
um so what this what this means is that
this notion of having you know
the system act as its own heat buff so
region b acting as the heat bar for
region a
um is incompatible with having electrons
localized in the sense of anderson
localization
so
localization and
we call this eth
so thermodynamics is a close quantum
system those are really incompatible
um so one of the two must give way
right so there's two possibilities if i
have 1d electrons in this limit
well either
localization gets destroyed because
interactions lead to something you know
lead to the validity of this picture and
lead to something like variable range
hopping it would be similar to coupling
the system to phonons
and so localization would be destroyed
by interactions
the alternative picture is that eth
breaks down so if you consider highly
excited states of such a system all of
what i said here
would not apply
anymore um right so basically the
question now is which of these two
scenarios is realized does localization
uh prevail or does uh thermalization
prevail
and um
this was actually if you look at the
introduction of anderson's paper in 1958
you see that he already realized this he
already says that an anderson insulator
is the first example of a system where
thermodynamics or statistical mechanics
breaks down because that's
non-interacting case and the question of
whether you know that survives in the
interacting case has been open basically
for 50 years since
um
and then maybe this is the only
reference i'm going to put down
there was a seminal paper by vasco
alaina and alchula
in 2006
who made huge progress on answering this
question and claimed that indeed if you
add interactions
localization prevails at least for weak
enough interactions
and
statistical mechanics would break down
and so i want to spend another couple of
minutes on explaining the picture that
was put forward by bhaskar aligner and
also
then try to explain why using that
picture in a numerical calculation
is very difficult and why it doesn't
give a very transparent understanding of
what a many body localized state is
and then
finally connect kind of to the topics of
this conference and explain how we can
obtain a better understanding of of many
body localization maybe not so much
using tensor network states but at least
using a language that is very much
inspired by transactional states so
that's hopefully going to connect
back to the other topics of this
conference
so the perspective that
was discussed in this paper is that of
localization in fox space
there's actually a very old concept was
discussed in the 80s to understand
localization in mesoscopic system so to
understand crossover and level
statistics and quantum dots
and then the achievement of this paper
was to apply this same language to an
extended system and somehow take the
thermodynamic limit and control way so
what do i mean by that
um so let me
think about a hamiltonian that has this
form
so i have some
let me just uh take uh say spinless
fermions so i have some non-interacting
disordered fermion hamiltonian
and now i add some kind of weak
interaction
so this lambda is going to be
much weaker than the disorder
and this is some kind of physically
local interaction term between the
fermions
now i could imagine solving the single
particle
problem so i'm going to find
the slated determinants that solve this
that's a good question
yes so when you say
disorder you mean there is on-site
random potential this is the diagonal
disorder yeah i mean the the specific
type of disorder doesn't matter so much
i want this to be an anison insulator so
let's say uncorrelate i mean the
simplest case would be uncorrelated
diagonal disorder
um
you could probably also take this
quasi-disordered system the details
shouldn't really matter that much but if
it's not diagonal
well i think there's some confusion in
the literature so if you look at
anderson's papers he calls hopping
interaction
um
yeah and
by interaction i mean it turned it
involves four feminine
four four
so this is a bunch of two feminine
operators this quadratic in familial
operators and this is quartic in terms
of
um right
so
i have some set of slater determinants
we call these alpha
these are occupational number vectors
in terms of some orbitals that solve
this single particle problem and so
there's two to the l of these
and now using these i could revise
completely equivalently this hamiltonian
in the following form
so now i have some completely diagonal
part here in this later determinant this
is just a single particle part of it
and then the interaction now looks like
this so if you look at this hamiltonian
this looks exactly like what we expect
the anderson hamiltonian to look like
the non-interacting anderson hamiltonian
of course what i've done is just a trick
i had a
system that started out on l sites and
that is interacting now i have a
non-interacting system but it's not two
to the l sides
so computationally i haven't made
anything easier i've just rewritten it
in a different language
yeah let's say this is symmetric
um
but the picture put forward in this
basket and also paper is that this is
actually a very useful representation
of the hamiltonian and the idea is that
um you could think of many body
localization as localization on some
very complicated graph that's defined by
this hamiltonian so these v alpha beta
these define some kind of graph
on which the single particle problem
lives this is some random possibly
highly coordinated graph of 2dl sites
and so you can now try and solve a
anderson localization problem on random
graphs on beta lattices on all kinds of
things that you would think approximate
this
um and you could try to understand many
body localization in this way
and um
you know then you could apply all the
machinery that you have a single
particle localization you could
calculate inverse participation ratios
and so on and try to see whether that
gives you any insights into many body
localization now it turns out that um
analytically at least you know in this
perturbative calculation of buscar line
and also this is a useful perspective
but um if you try to use this
numerically
you don't get much out of it so
you know this is some extremely
complicated graph you can try to analyze
the structure of this graph you find
that it has an extensive coordination
number
so as you grow the system size the
coordination of this graph grows so that
already sounds pretty ill defined
if you calculate inverse participation
ratios
you see that you know all the eigen
states are actually delocalized in some
very strict sense and maybe you could
analyze the precise scaling but it all
turns out to be very difficult so making
this notion of localization and fox
based precise in this sense turns out to
be very hard so what we then thought is
maybe we can
make that more precise by using a
language of tender network states a
language at least inspired by tensor
network states in the limit lambda equal
to zero you wouldn't lose this
interaction right yeah so if plum is
very small do you get any insight at all
this this graph does does it buy at all
or it's just complicated times lambda
it's just complicated and small yeah
i mean then then
what so what basketball and alchemy do
is they take this and they simplify this
so they kind of cut off
this interaction in space and in energy
um and if you simplify this enough you
end up with a problem that's
perturbatively tractable
but numerically if you try to go beyond
that it turns out to be really hard
um
but the
the idea that that
this gives you is that
the many body localized states are
somehow
slightly washed out in fox space from uh
the states of some adjacent anderson
insulator and so you have
you have fox space
if you have
a non-interacting problem
your ground state is just a point in
this
if you have if you now add interactions
it kind of gets washed out a little bit
but it doesn't get washed out enough to
change the properties of the system
fundamentally so it doesn't get washed
out enough to lead to transport and so
on
yes so they understand that
at least
but physically there's always if
if you have some localized things things
will kind of maybe hop or contract close
by but you will act like the identity
far away
yes just to map even to model this in
this language you need exponential
because the identity kind of has
extension many times far away so see
what kind of thing but this is not a
very useful
so they can only be polynomial i mean
there's at least n to the four
non-venturing terms here anyway
right there's only end to the four four
familiar products you can buy
oh wait this is
this this is basically a way of encoding
the fourth thermal term so i think the
question was the size of h
but this is not a pure thing
this is exactly the same matrix as this
just written in a different basis
so epsilon alpha is the sum of the
single particle energies of all the
occupied altitudes in translated
determinations
if you just take the free
non-interacting case and you add one
interaction between two sides just two
sides
then it won't have a clear structure
the locality
won't reflect nicely on this the
alphabet right
i know it will it will
simpler so the graph will be fairly
simple and so so but this mixes terms
that satan determines that differ by at
most two
orbiters right but there are many of
those
yeah but if they if they differ in very
far away places then this is going to be
very small
so individual terms are nice but when
you put all the local terms together
yeah basically the complication comes
from the fact that if you you know one
fermion can only hop to a few other
places but you have extensively many
feminines
and you have to multiply all the places
where they can hop
and that's where the fact that this is
extensive coordination comes from
okay
but the
the picture here that i should think of
these um
inter states of the interacting system
as somehow washed out a little bit in
fog space
is very much akin to the way we think
about
the uh ground state of a gap than
topologically non-trivial system right
so the way you would think about that is
you have
you have some type of you know i don't
want to deal with topological systems at
this point that's going to come in later
um so ground state of such a system just
a completely trivial state
um
is basically related to product states
so i can think of that as you know a
superposition of a bunch of product
states basically but this notion is of
course made precise by tensor network
states
and one way to
think about this is that there's an
adiabatic path tuning between some
hamiltonian over here
i'm introducing some parameter and say
this is for s equal to one
and some some other hamiltonian over
here
and all the the ground state of this
hamiltonian is simply a product
and you want this to be gapped and you
want a gap path between
uh
between these two hamiltonians
and then you can write some kind of
adiabatic time revolution operator that
goes from
the product stage that is completely
trivial to the ground states of your gap
then topologically trivial hamiltonian
and so this notion we would like to
apply also to understanding the
einsteins of a many body localized
system as kind of related by some
adiabatic
continuation to the einsteins of an
anderson insulator
so i'm going to relate mbl eigenstates
to
anderson insulator
now this notion doesn't apply quite
straightforwardly right um here was
talking about the ground state so
thinking about is a grantee that's
separated from the rest of the spectrum
by a gap makes sense
here i'm talking about arbitrary high
energy eigenstates of the system
so you know the bandwidth is
polynomially large in the system size
the number of states is exponential so
just by that counting argument the gaps
to adjacent states must be exponentially
small so there's no way i can think of
something like a gapped path
but what i can think about
is a relation given by finite depth
local unitary circuits
so the way i want to define this
relation so this is some kind of
notion of adiabatically connected
and
the technically useful thing that i can
do for excited eigenstate is think about
states that are
related by finite depth local unitary
circuit
so what i mean i mean this is probably
pretty obvious in this audience
is something that looks like this
so i'm going to call this vertical
direction the depth
do you consider a
different uh
military circuit for each item state i'm
going to come to that that's a very good
question
uh i will talk about that in a minute
um
but yeah at this point i want to allow
that at this point i just want to
continue states of an interacting system
into localized states of some free
fermion system and in principle i just
can allow myself a different unitary for
every state
so this is of course kind of the same as
you know
the notion of having a gapped path and
some adiabatic connection you can turn
into this notion by just you know
expanding that unitary operator
cauterizing it and that will give you a
finite depth vocal unitary where the
depth is basically the time so that's
going to be related to the inverse gap
yes the fact that you will allow finance
related effect that you will only treat
finite localization
let
um well there's a bit of a trick here so
i'm not continuing to product states but
to iron states of an innocence left
which can have exponential tails
so the the reason of not writing product
states over here is that i can kind of
push the whole problem of dealing with
exponential tails into the existing
literature analysis insulators and those
existing literature that relates these
two product states
that's that's why this doesn't say polyx
over here
um yes do you really mean or you just
said that the
time would be
related to ginger's cap i think that's
not what you want well in this non-state
case it is
but in the in the many body localized
case that's not going to be
i don't i don't think that's really what
it would be
it doesn't have to be
adiabatic here we really need this
quasi-idiomatic
right notion yeah these things
so
i mean because if the time would be
related to the inverse capital it would
be really bad
so but you don't need ads
so the claim is basically that
many body localization can be defined in
a useful way where you know this depth
is somehow not related to but in the
ground case it's also not true it's also
not related okay
um right so
question yes your definition of medicine
is
yes yes so want the tails to decay
faster than a polynomial
um
so
so let me just write down the definition
that we proposed from anybody localized
so
all right so i required that so i'm
going to call this state many body
localized if there exists some finite
that look unitary that will almost
everywhere transform psi in terms of
into translator determinant to desired
accuracy
so you're probably wondering now why
these caveats while they're almost
everywhere and why they well the to
design accuracy is probably more obvious
um
and i'm going to come to why these are
important in a minute they actually turn
out to be pretty important to have a
reliable definition
yes so
by state now you mean a particular state
or do you mean a phase of matter what do
you mean at this point i mean a
particular eyeing state of some
hamiltonian
so but for a particular grounds uh
instead of a hamiltonian you don't need
a definition of anybody localization
right i mean if it's just a state
you could say this is this is um a
product state deformed by a quantum
circuit
i mean that's basically what i'm saying
i know i know but but i mean this this
notion
um
does not have to be attached to the
phenomenon of many body localization it
happens there but
it's much more general right you're
saying you have a quantum
state that can be transforming to a
product state
um yeah or almost a private state right
i mean yes to the point is these are the
eigenstates of this
no no but i'm going to use this
definition to define a many body
localized system given by some
hamiltonian as one where almost all
eigenstates fulfill this definition so
i'm using this as a stepping stone to
get to the definition of a many body
localized phase and what you're saying
is this concept should not be very
strange to us no no i mean for this
audience this should be completely
familiar yeah if you give this to other
audiences they're like what the hell is
all this but uh yeah i mean this is like
this would actually be my first
coalition of this definition so the
first thing that you see is that this is
basically
saying that these states have an nps
description in one dimension right
because an nps is nothing else that a
finite depth local unitary applied to a
product state
so
for this audience i could have probably
just said
in one dimension the eigen states are
described by matrix fallout 6.
all eigenstates not just the ones that
all eigenstates of the system are
described by matrix folic states now
there's of course a bit of a caveat here
when you want to do simulations which is
how you find this matrix body statement
so this definition suggests that it
should exist
but of course you know at some state in
the middle of the spectrum and finding
it would be very hard and if we
explained yesterday how you would do it
if you were given some uh constants of
motion of the hamiltonian but in general
how to do that is still an open problem
and you know there may or may not be a
solution to that
um
this also immediately implies that these
states have an aerial law
all right so finite that will unitary
can only add so much entanglement to the
system follow state has zero
entanglement so these must have an area
along and this is a very important
consequence because this definition you
know if you just give me a state this is
hard to check numerically i don't know
how to construct this unitary uh very
efficiently but if i'm given the state i
can just measure the entropy so this
gives me a numerical way to study many
body localization and this is of course
what we were aiming for here also
um
if you look at the definitions of many
body localization given by basket line
and alcohol all of those you know that's
like transport i don't know how to
calculate transport efficiently
in a strongly interacting disordered
system um i do know how to calculate
entanglement entropies reasonably
efficiently so this gives me a good way
to check numerically yes actually i have
a question about eigenstates in the
middle of the spectrum this is not a
well-defined concept though because you
know like yeah well right so you can
always take your inner combinations of
them and that's still an eigenstate
so yeah is that more saying that there
exists a linear combination of those
that right that's actually a very good
question so that's something we're
thinking about right now um you know if
you think about something that you could
do in a lab in finite time
you can only prepare eigenstate to some
accuracy so you're going to have a
superposition of eyeing state in an
energy window and the question is does
that tell you something about
localization and it turns out that it
does so you can read off signs of
localization from approximate
eigenstates as well
um so you can kind of for example you
can see an area law emerge in states
that you can prepare in polynomial time
by quantum circuit
or starting from a product state
um
i don't want to deal with that question
in this talk maybe but
we've been thinking about how to study
all this on a quantum computer where
that comes up i'd be happy to explain
that maybe in part of it
um
right
so another interesting point here is uh
i've allowed this
unitary u to be different for every
eyeing state
now let's additionally assume that i
have some hamiltonian h
h and
u is the same for all eigenstate
thanks
right so this is a slightly stronger
definition i'm not allowing myself to
choose a u for every state but i want to
have one u that acts on the whole
spectrum and transform it transforms it
to polar states so now you can
take this hamiltonian
h you can
conjugate it by that unitary you get
some new hamiltonian h tilde now this
hamiltonian h tilde
all its eigen states are basically
product states so it should be diagonal
in some local basis
so you know i can just assume that that
basis is z
and then what i get is that this h tilde
looks like this
so it's the sum of products of pauli z
operators now this will of course look
very familiar from uh give his talk
yesterday
uh so these are the these sigmas are the
local constants of motion well i haven't
said local yet but they're they're at
least constants of motion under this
hamiltonian h tilde you can convince
yourself that they're local by
calculating some operator that's um
so
this is you know on the side in this new
letters here this is a finite depth
operator so it has a light cone
so this can only transform a local
operator into a local operator so
physically these operators sigma z
are
local in the original letters so what
that means is that if i assume that this
u is the same for all states
our definition implies the definition um
by a local conserved quantities you can
also go the other way
but that's actually much harder so i'm
not going to go into that
you're assuming
i'm assuming there's no mobility as
indeed yeah if you have a mobility edge
i think it gets tricky
yeah this is indeed very strong so
i've assumed here that there's no
mobility edge i've also assumed that i
can kind of forget about my almost
everywhere
and to you know
in this definition i'm going to see that
i actually need to allow regions where
this definition is not does not apply
and so i don't quite know what happens
if you carefully treat these constants
of motions
given that you have regions where kind
of the definition doesn't apply so i've
assumed a very strong version of our
definition and then i can then it
implies the constants of motion
no so i'm
well i'm not allowed to show any
numerical data if i were i could now
show that
let's say there are phases of matter
that are consistent with this definition
in the sense of having an area for all
lying states
um
so this would be the canonical thing to
do now
um
yes yes
um
so right
you can now take some uh canonical
system you know three families on the
chain with the next neighbor interaction
um you can study the area law
so you just look at the entanglement in
the system and you see that there's a
parameter regime where you have finite
interactions but on all the system sizes
that are accessible
um
it's consistent with many body
localization but you can also make the
interactions very strong and drive it
out of this phase so you can drive
delocalization by making very strong
interactions
um
so you know there's a kind of a finite
window this is for some particular model
um other authors have actually looked at
entanglement properties and detected
mobility edges
right so frank has worked on that
instead of looking at the
area law you look at kind of by
fluctuations around if you look at the
variance of the entropy and then you can
in certain systems at least detected
many body mobility edge so that not all
eigenstates are local
okay so you just mentioned for all
system sizes that can be analyzed um so
is it should we be concerned that maybe
this is a finite size effect or
right i have an opinion about that well
you should always be concerned about
finite size effects um
there's a handwaving argument that um
it's unlikely to find a scenario where
you know if you plot entanglement
entropy and let's say plot the mean as a
function of system size you know you see
an area law and then it takes off
that this seems extremely unlikely right
because then locally the system would
have to be localized and at large scales
it somehow delocalization has to happen
that seems extremely unlikely
um but i cannot prove that it doesn't
happen so the the more likely scenario
and the one that you see in the
pneumatics is that you have some kind of
world that small system sizes
and then it saturates
to an area so this is supposed to be
perfectly flat
so that you know that gives us some
trust that in this direction we can kind
of trust
um the numerics even for relatively
small system i mean numerically you know
this is like
up to 80 inside or so because we have to
do full diagonalization very very time
consuming now
what i've plotted here is the following
so
i'm calculating some eigen state of the
system
and touching it somewhere so i have
two blocks and then i calculate the
entangled entropy for this
right so now what i'm plotting what i'm
kind of sketching here
is the scenario where i
always cut in the center of an open
chain and then i average over
eigenstates
and then i average over disorder
realizations
and then i observe an area law there's a
different thing i can do
um
i can take the maximum over l
this is little l
average that over eigen states
and then average that over this order
right so instead of always cutting in
the same place which is kind of cutting
in an average place i maximize over the
place where i cut in the system
and very interestingly then you observe
a completely different scaling so then
instead of seeing an area law
you see something that looks like log l
so for every eyeing state
nearly every eigenstate i can find a
place where i can cut the system
such that the entropy is not quite
extensive
but scales in some very slow way with
the system size
and so that
now tells you why we put all these
caveats in the definition in particular
that's almost everywhere so it cannot
require that the system has an aerial
law everywhere that it it's you know
related to a product state everywhere
um but i have some kind of very small
fraction of the system and you know in
this numerically it looks like that's
basically log l over l so it's a
vanishing fraction of the system in the
thermodynamic limit but there are still
kind of regions where the system
violates
an area law and has kind of a
sub-extensive but growing entropy
um there's a
i just want to quickly
sketch this
kind of an intuitive way to understand
this um so you can think of this all
realizations
um
you know you just look at some disorder
realization you have flat regions and
you have regions where the disorder
potential varies strongly so you have
kind of a flat region
and then you have a barrier
and let's say the probability of having
a barrier at a given site
is p
um then the probability
of
oh yeah and so that what defines a flat
region
um flat means basically on the scale of
the critical disorder strength
the
the disorder potential looks flat so
it's somehow flat enough to lead to
delocalization between the two barriers
that surround this region
so the probability of having
if i if i just pick a location then the
probability of being surrounded by such
a region of size s
is uh
1 minus this probability to the power s
so this probability is exponentially
small
but now if i uh this is somewhat cutting
at the center
if i now look everywhere in the system
the probability of having a region of
size s that's flat anywhere in the
system gets an additional factor l in
front
so then this probability is not just
exponentially suppressed but there's an
additional logarithmic term
up in the exponent so it only becomes
extremely where
once you consider an s that's kind of
larger than log l so this is a hand
waving way to understand what we see in
the numerics
uh by seeing this log our growth in the
average maximum entropy in eigenstates
um
okay so i have 15 minutes
let's see so bella if you take then
a cut for a given egg instead of
hamiltonian you take a cut
and if it's in the middle always the
probability that you get local is small
but once you get to the proper cut where
this you have locale then presumably you
have local for i mean the entropy
doesn't go from constant to locale
um
right so you have a you have all these
flat regions
log l is basically i mean you only
saturate the log l if you happen to cut
in the middle of the
log l size region right but if you got
one side
next to it it's going to be local minus
one
so does this tell you that you should
expect in in terms of the discussion of
integrals of motion that you should
expect somewhere localized integral
yes
i mean
i'm actually not completely sure how to
understand this but you know you could
maybe think that there would be
integrals of motion that is strictly low
class and some that spread out over
large l sites right okay at least have a
have a parallel decay
of a larger sense
so i
i i didn't completely concern this with
this result of joel moore and the
they kind of look at the random spin
chain and then somehow they they
actually show that the environmentally
is always always scales like lock l
exactly because of randomness
because
that's my question
that's the difference
yeah i think this is a different type of
disorder if you're looking at bond
disorder there's some sort of
criticality right here yeah and i think
that's basically if you would do the
same for the site disorder you would not
see this block growth it would just look
like all right
well it depends if then you can have
like a random random diamond model where
the disorder is not completely
uncorrelated but um two adjacent sides
always have the same just other
potential i think so you have some
correlation in the disorder then in one
dimension you can have a critical point
like if you just have diagnose order
you know any disorder will immediately
localize the system if you have
correlated disorder you can have a
transition at a finite disorder strength
and i think in those cases you would get
this log l behavior at the critical
point
it's a very different setup
so in particular i'm sitting deep in the
face i'm not you know at the phase
transition you know you could imagine
that the phase transitions happened by
having these long outside regions grow
and kind of percolate i'm not sure if
that's a good picture for the transition
or not
um but that's i'm not even addressing
that question here
um
so
i think this rg is kind of in a
different setup that's why i get a
different result so i don't think this
logo is necessarily called you know
connected to that log l
um
yeah and
then we said this is only in certain
regions of this system this is not in
the average like if you take
if you take say
quantiles of
you take the distribution of cutting
everywhere every quartile of that will
converge
but the maximum will divert
it's very different
um
okay
so
yeah
you cannot sit down and
try to make this
informal definition here
um very precise taking into account all
these rare regions effects and so on
that ends up being very technical
um
i thought a bit about how to present it
in a non-technical way
uh let me just state it in words
basically so by two design accuracy we
mean that um by measuring k local
operators you cannot distinguish these
two states
um
with the probability larger than some
epsilon that you get to pick
um so we're only requiring a bound on
trace norm distances of local reduced
density matrices and we cannot
require something like the overlap of
states to be large because that'll be
they'll be completely killed by these
rare regions and then we have to kind of
very carefully ask the question of how
to approach the thermodynamic limit so
we work around that by only requiring
that k local
uh correlators for some k that you
choose beforehand cannot distinguish and
then for this almost everywhere you have
to work pretty hard to be able to
approach the thermodynamic limit in a
controlled way in the definition so you
kind of take a
series of hyphen cubes that eventually
fill the whole lattice and you pick some
fraction of some fraction f strictly
smaller than one
um and then out of every one of these
hypercubes you select some sub region of
volume at least f
um
on which this definition holds and then
you can kind of take the
take the thermodynamic limit in a
controlled way and so finally then we
can we can use this definition to define
a manually localized phase
as as as a phase described by some
hamiltonian age
that um
where
almost all eigen states have this
property almost all meaning that um
kind of the
the probability of
you know there exists some d
such that the probability of finding a
state where you need a depth larger than
d is exponentially small
and an additional requirement you
probably want to add is that this is
stable to slightly changing the
hamiltonian so you know that you can
allow some you can add some small
finite perturbation um and this property
survives otherwise you'll get kind of
all kinds of trivial systems that
fulfill this you could just take an
easing model without field and it'll
fulfill this definition but it will not
as soon as you add any magnetic field
um
so if you're interested in all the
glorious detail
you can look that up in the paper i can
explain it later um and use the last 10
minutes
to
kind of sketch out an idea um which is
actually why we originally started
thinking about this which is the
possibility of having topological order
uh
at finite temperature
in such a system
and this is an idea that that was at the
same time uh discussed by other groups
so uh david hughes and his collaborators
and princeton have started this and
actually ashwin and his collaborators
have worked on this question as well in
the 1d system
so what's the problem with having
topological order at finite temperature
so let's consider just for simplicity a
system on a on a cylinder you can
imagine the toy code but the same
argument would apply basically to any
um topological phase and maybe you want
to
imagine this not being at a fixed point
in the sense that quality particles
actually have some dispersion it can be
very weak this person but you don't want
to be you know at a fixed point where
closer particles don't move at all
so you prepare your system in some gone
state
but let's say it's somehow coupled to an
external bot you have you know cosmic
rays coming in that put energy into the
system something like this
um and what will happen is that you can
create a pair of quality particles
or strictly speaking particle
antiparticle pair
um
this will be some finite energy
excitation above the ground state
but if i'm at finer temperature
um you know there's a finite probability
for that happening
now
if these closet particles have some
dispersants
they've kind of created this pair
locally so they sit very close to each
other
now they have some dispersion so they're
going to go move around so you can
imagine taking one of the two
and having having it kind of diffuse
around the system and come back to its
original locations
so i'm going to take one of these
particles and move it around the
cylinder
so now it's come back to its original
location so you can annihilate it with
its you know brother
and so now i'm back in the ground state
manifold because i have no
quasi-particle excitations anymore
um the energy that i have you know
someone gets pushed into the thermal
bath or i emit some
you know photon or whatever um
and i'm back in the ground state
manifold but i'm not back in the state
where i started right if one of these
particles moved along a topologically
non-trivial loop say around the cylinder
i've actually changed the state of my
system
and the probability for this whole
procedure
is
exponentially small in the gap
right so the probability for firmly
creating this pair
is exponentially small in the energy of
the pair over the temperature
but there's no well okay and then
there's the process of moving it around
the cylinder which is going to be
polynomially suppressed in the system
size
right so you can imagine maybe it's a
diffusive process so then it's like one
of us
l squared basically maybe there's some
factor for having it come back to its
original location but this is not
exponentially suppressed in the system
size there's only polynomially
suppressed in the system size
so this is the argument that is usually
given for why topological order or
topological quantum memories are going
to be unstable at any finite temperature
um
but now
if you take t to infinity it's your best
it seems like if you make t arbitrarily
large
you have high probability of success
am i supposed to say this is t over
delta
yes
yeah
so i don't understand why it's
why it's polynomial suppression if my
particle has some mass i expect the the
action to be like the mass times the
length of its worldwide as it goes
around the cylinders so shouldn't it be
like e to the minus mass times the
radius of the cylinder
um
i mean if you just think of like if you
know say you have a system where you
have diffuser transport but then this
particle is going to execute some kind
of random walk
right and so random walk has a
polynomially small probability of coming
back to its original location
crossing
suppression if you have zero temperature
right that's never the yeah the
suppression at zero temperature but he
has final temperature so the energy is
available it is not the real gold
parabolic it's a real
pattern but i mean in the last one even
if you
even if you don't think so much about
finer temperature but like you know
cosmic ray exciting this pair
um if you then have some dispersion for
these particles they will diffuse now
once once they're once they're created
they're not confined
so they you know there's no the string
that's kind of
connecting them is not physical doesn't
have any string tension so you can just
move them around
um okay but this is kind of suggestive
already in the context of what i've said
for how i can fix this right so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to localize the
quality particles
and so if i localize these plastic
particles i've basically broken the
second step so
i can still locally create particle
anti-particle pairs
but they are they're not
you know they're exponentially
suppressed from moving around the silver
they just don't diffuse anymore they're
just stuck in their location so you can
create them you can kind of locally
annihilate them but the probability of
having them go along a non-trivial loop
around the system is exponentially small
so instead of having one little poly
here
this is not now going to be
exponentially small
in l over some
uh
some characteristic length scale which
is going to be the localization
so by doing this i've kind of fixed this
problem with topological phases at
finite temperature
now generically these quasi particles
are interacting
so
to be able to localize them i need to
know that many body localization exists
so
these are interacting
and so therefore i need many body
localization so i need to find a
parameter regime in these models where
the quasi particles are manually
localized but i've not destroyed kind of
the underlying
topological background of the state
um
and okay so in my last two minutes let
me just write down
a specific example where we would hope
this would happen
so for example you could just consider a
toy code
so i have my vertex terms
and now to give the quasi particles some
dispersant let me add a magnetic field
let me add magnetic field in two
directions so that both electric and
magnetic particles
um kind of get moved around by the
action of this
of this magnetic field and now i'm going
to add this order to this
so i'm going to choose these um
these terms here
to be disordered
so
we can just add box disorder around some
uh
so some some some window of this order w
some uniform distributions from the the
both the uh
vertex and the plaqueton i'm going to
choose the coupling from some
disorder distribution that has some uh
mean
uh that is finite
right
positive
yes yes yes so i'm going to write that
down in a second so the interesting
regime is where these magnetic fields
which are basically the hopping
uh terms for these quasi-particles are
much smaller than this disorder strength
w
but at the same time this w needs to be
much smaller than
the
mean value of the uh plaquette and
vertex term
right so this is the regime where we
expect this to happen so all of this
happens on a scale that is much smaller
than the gap the gap is set by these
right so if i make this this all the
strong compared to the gap i'm just
completely going to destroy everything
in the system so that's not good
um so i need a regime where the gap is
very large this order is small compared
to the gap
but this order is strong compared to the
hopping terms for the quasi particles
and so this would be the regime where i
expect the quasi particles to be many
body localized
and thus this topological phase to be
stable at finite temperatures and indeed
in this case maybe in
at in all eight states
of the system
um
this is of course a very hard problem to
study in normality numerically you can
then
uh look at some 1d symmetry protected
phase and kind of reach a similar
parameter regime and this was actually
done by ashwin and his collaborators
some 1d uh symmetry protector chain
where you can observe that the edge
states remain stable
at very high energy densities if you if
you tune into a similar parameter
machine
and yeah because i'm out of time so uh
yeah
thank you and okay
so in this last discussion what was the
role of having
sufficiently large happen is it because
you wanted to be sufficiently small
temperatures with respect to the gap or
not well
so it may not be so obvious in the
toilet but for example um if you if you
would try to do this for a uh
like a majorana chain like a kitive
model in 1d if you make the on-site
disorder large compared to the gap you
actually drive a phase transition into
this marijuana metal phase
so you would get delocalized states at
low energies driven by disorder so some
kind of griffith effect would lead to
delocalization
it's not clear whether the same would
happen in the tory code but
something like that would probably
happen you'd have regions that are out
of the topological phase entirely but
then you still wanted i mean at least to
be safe are you asking that the gap be
large enough yeah and
how do you foresee how do you think
about preparing this system i mean we
don't have thermalization there right so
i don't know what temperature means
yes the temperature is a bit of a
i try to avoid it in most of it this is
really um at finite energy density so
for example in this in this 1d setup
what you can do is instead of preparing
the system in a low energy state you
prepare the system in a completely
random polar state which is basically a
very high energy state and then you
observe that even in that high energy
initial state as you consider the
dynamics of the system the edge states
remains stable
and you know if they grow the system
size the the time scale for the edge uh
grows exponentially
like for for this protection of this
quantum order is does pure localization
enough
or i mean if i if i look at this model
and i say okay now i find that the
system is in a many by localized state
does it automatically tell me that i
have protected quantum water or do i
also have to consider maybe the defect
density or
i remember like in david maybe there's
some regime yeah yeah yeah
um localized power market and only if
the localization length is short
compared to the average distance of
defense yeah yeah it's actually
protected yeah i think
basically all the
other conservations that previously
applied to having male ready
localization for your original degrees
of freedom now applies to having
many body localization for the
excitations
um so if you you know if the
if the quality particles are so dense
that the localization volume overlaps
that would basically mean that the
hopping becomes very large
so let's see
water is washed off yeah yeah
yeah i mean i should have maybe said
that having topological order final
temperature is as one example out of a
general paradigm of having point of
order
at finite temperature i think the phrase
was used by david hughes and i mean for
example you can observe quantum spin
glasses at finite temperature and all
kinds of concepts
do you
see any room for having some phase that
the size was the sweet definition of
them but not the stronger one
uh do you know any example that's a very
good question um
well so the question is um is it
actually important that we allow this u
to be different for all like states
or you know is
is it for all physical models actually
sufficient to take one year for the
whole spectrum
um
i mean okay so there's the problem of
having a mobility edge
um
but but if you consider stays there kind
of below the mobility edge i really
don't know
right so i can't show anything
um
there's
there's kind of obvious problems in one
direction so if you
um
if you wanna if you wanna
show that this implies an area law uh
here we only apply k in a
1k local operators to be within some
accuracy on the transform distance
um that's probably not enough to show an
area like even if you have things that
are very close and traced on distance on
uh like you know locally they can have
completely different entanglement
properties at least if you look at kind
of naive bounds so all of these proofs
for for having area loss in in in 1d
systems and so on imply the locality of
the hamiltonian and the gap and so on
actually doesn't go like this at all but
you need to leave vomits and bonds
things like that um
so maybe somebody who understands how to
prove like the area law in 1d very
deeply can make this precise but it
seems very difficult
i think physically it seems kind of
intuitive i mean
physically it seems to be hard to
imagine that you can have eigenstates of
a local hamiltonian um that fulfill one
but not the other definition
um but i can't make that mathematically
which two
uh having the standard that wasn't
unitary and having an area
almost all but what about symmetry
breaking i mean
oh all of them
you have a gsj
right
yes would you accept that one because it
fulfills the areola but you cannot find
this oh but it doesn't fulfill the uh
kind of
stability to uh conserving the
hamiltonian
because i've talked mostly about states
but as soon as you talk about the
hamiltonian you need to include that
otherwise there's a ton of trivial
examples like that
um
but all of those are unstable to adding
a small federation
there's no more questions
again
so now we have lunch break and then we
resume at 1 30.